thank you
welcome to session 69 in the worlds of
speculative fiction series if you're new
to this I'll tell you all about it in
just a minute but first I want to
highlight the work that we're going to
be considering and going through and
delving into in this particular session
it is blue Mars by Kim Stanley Robinson
which is as you might know the
culmination of this entire series or as
he's going to tell us in an interview
that we'll look at a little bit later
one single gigantic novel red Mars green
Mars blue Mars taking place over a span
of hundreds of years and in a pretty
vast Panorama which will extend to the
entirety of the solar system by about
two-thirds of the way through blue Mars
the first two books are primarily about
Earth and Mars and the colonization and
terraforming the making you know
Earth-like or Earth similar we should
say earthoid the Martian landscape and
entire Echo System creating one so
worlds of speculative fiction
is a series that we started back in 2016
largely as an excuse for me to do some
guilty pleasure reading in speculative
fiction going back to Classics of
science fiction fantasy horror and other
genres as well it was hosted by the
Brookfield public library and went on
from
2016 to early 2020 2020 was of course
the year of kovid so everybody had to
stay at home and we couldn't go to the
library anymore for our in-depth
discussions that we were holding and
eventually I figured out how to do it
online like we're doing here so what we
do is I'll present for about 90 minutes
some of which is going to be you know
bringing up particularly important
passages from the text and talking about
philosophical themes we're also going to
talk a lot about world building because
it is Worlds of speculative fiction and
if it was the first session on Robinson
I would be doing biography as we did in
the previous one talking about you know
when his Works came out and his life and
all of that we're not going to do that
this time around but we will be looking
at some additional interviews that are
very revealing about the Mars Trilogy in
general about blue Mars and about his
thoughts about the major themes of say
environmentalism or Utopia or
sustainability or where humanity is
going that plays such a major role
within these texts so what we're going
to be doing first is I don't want to you
know jump right into the interviews
although they provide some great locuses
for what we're are going to discuss I'd
like to talk a bit about the World
building in Broad outlines that isn't
just happening in these two Works we're
actually going to be leaving these more
or less behind but the World building
happening in blue Mars itself World
building here is going to be a rather
loaded term as we're going to see and
then you know we'll look at some of
these really important interviews and
what they have to reveal and then we'll
talk about major
philosophical themes that come up and
are explored and outlined sometimes in
the mouths of characters in blue Mars
and then we'll bring it to a successful
close this is of course the second of
two sessions in the first session we
worked our way through red Mars and
green Mars now we're coming to an end of
this particular series and as we're
gonna see in the interviews Kim Stanley
Robinson himself although he's you know
very happy about the work that he did in
the Mars Trilogy doesn't actually think
that these do provide us with a
blueprint anymore for the possible
colonization of Mars and and but they do
provide us with modes of thinking about
these matters and they're a great story
as well which should never be left aside
when we're talking about fiction
is it something that's not just teaching
us or presenting us with interesting
models or thought experiments does it
entertain and I think that the answer
for uh these Works red Mars green Mars
and blue Mars is that
um you know Kim Stanley Robinson does
manage to pull that off at many points
so settle in we're gonna talk about the
World building going on in these novels
and in particularly in blue Mars and
then we'll look at some interesting
interviews then we'll talk about some
big philosophical themes zeroing in on
important passages within the work
this video series is called worlds of
speculative fiction so World building is
really quite Central to it and more and
more of that is happening as we progress
from Red Mars to Green Mars to Blue Mars
which we're looking at today
and as I remarked in the previous
session where we were discussing these
first two volumes in the massive novel
that Robinson has put together here
spanning three different books
there's not just World building in the
conventional sense of you know thinking
about like well what are what is the
continents and where is the weather
going and what are the peoples and maybe
I'll do something on their language
instead Robinson is taking our world
namely Earth and our solar system and
the most easily terraformable
colonizable planet Mars
and then he's developing
entire worlds out of that so he's not
beginning with a completely new
narrative Universe he is projecting
ahead and as we're going to see I'm
talking about in interviews this is
really quite important the fact that
it's not you know Space Opera located in
the galaxy flitting from planet to
planet with Myriad exotic cultures or
some fantasy novel instead this is about
building and transforming a world and
the world of course that's talked about
most is Mars which makes perfect sense
but Mars doesn't exist it couldn't exist
as a human world in isolation from the
mother World Earth and there's going to
be lots and lots of back and forth
intentions
by the midpoint or a little bit past the
midpoint of blue Mars it's no longer
going to be just Earth and Mars it'll
also be Venus and Mercury and going all
the way out to Uranus and you know
Jupiter and Saturn and all of this other
cool colonization stuff that's going on
but Earth and Mars are going to be kind
of driving it so I think that in order
to talk about World building we have to
be attentive to several different things
one is
four blue Mars there is indeed a
backstory an incredibly determinative
and important backstory from these first
two novels so we'll have to talk about
that a little bit and then we can talk
about Mars itself and the contrast
between you know there's many different
factions you could say but the most
important division is between the Reds
and the greens and their different
viewpoints on what should be done in
terraforming or area forming or with the
era funny right all these things that
are about aerys or Mars
and then we have to talk about
the fact that you know as as
Robinson is going to stress over and
over again we do have environments we do
have Landscapes we do have entire
planetary ecologies and we could even
say system ecologies right because
they're bringing things from outside of
Earth and Mars into Mars at certain
points
but we have to talk about human beings
and this is often where World building
goes right as I mentioned just a little
bit earlier classic World building let's
people some continents on a map with a
bunch of different uh distinct
ethnicities or tribes Each of which has
its own interesting history and perhaps
language okay that is World building
what Robinson is doing is projecting
human beings as they are forward several
hundred years in this Grand story so the
back story part right that we have to
discuss I think perhaps the most
important aspect that we can talk about
which is happening in each of these
books and is happening towards the end
of uh this this final book is the notion
of revolution
Earth sends up colonists for at first
just a hundred uh specially trained
scientists each of whom has been cleared
for certain things up to Mars on a
essentially one-way trip it would
actually it won't be completely one way
for a few of the original hundred and
they start building a colony on Mars you
know eventually developing a place under
Hill and all sorts of you know other
places around and they have divisions
about what they think Mars ought to look
like and pretty quickly things go off
the original plan the original script
that the the original mandate not least
because one of them hiroko smuggles a
hundred and first passenger a stowaway
on board Quixote right who is is she
knows we find this out much more in
green Mars but his sighted and and you
know eventually more and more people
start coming they build a gigantic space
elevator to facilitate that travel
and more and more colonists come from
Earth and there's a lot of discussions
and divisions about how precisely this
effort of colonization is going to work
some countries are seeing it as a
potential answer to the overpopulation
problems particularly India and China
but several others as well and the
original two main powers the United
States and Russia who are sending people
up it's hard to imagine at this point
that there would be this sort of
cooperation between the current United
States and and current Russia but these
are written back in the 90s of course so
you know there's treaties that are set
in place plans and these are fairly
quickly violated and ignored and you
know Earth attempts to assert a kind of
control over what's going to happen on
this developing planet of Mars political
local control economic control military
control you could even say ecological
control
and eventually the Martians fight back
there is an actual Revolution the space
elevator is is cut an incredible feat
it's attached to an asteroid up at the
top and
um this you know the the cord for the
elevator wraps around Mars at the
equator causing incredible Devastation
but Mars is able to attain a certain
degree of independence from the forces
on Earth that are attempting to control
to to guide to to colonize the colony
you could say right to steer it in a
very different direction where it would
be essentially an appendage subservient
to Earth and that's you know what
happens by the end of red Mars and
leading into green Mars they eventually
are going to build a second space
elevator and there's going to be all
sorts of back and forth things going on
you know developments happening on Earth
the you know transnational corporations
eventually become meta National
corporations much more powerful than
many countries start running the show
they actually fight against each other
some benign even benevolence uh meta
National organizations also arise
including the Swiss Praxis group and the
Martians themselves are trying to figure
out what are we going to do and there's
all these different competing visions
and models for how to steer the human
part of this rapidly changing evolving
Planet which we'll get to in just a bit
one of the massive
environmental matters that allows there
to be a second revolution which is
happening by the end of Green Mars
is an environmental catastrophe on Earth
and that environmental catastrophe
happens because of some volcanic
eruptions in Antarctica underneath the
ice shelf which causes the ice shelf at
least half of it to break off and fall
into the ocean raising ocean levels not
by you know the sort of little
projections that we have at present if
if global warming continues without
being checked you know where oh it's
going to rise six feet no it is in the
double digits which is just devastating
for countries that are you know
incredibly tied to their coastlines and
to their water levels and it causes
great suffering great instability all
across the Earth and leads to a
situation in which the Martians can once
again
not just Rebel or Revolt but have a
genuine Revolution where they are going
to change the Dynamics of power in
relation to the Earth and Mars and by
the beginning of blue Mars I mean it's
actually being discussed in green Mars
by the beginning of blue Mars the
Martians are saying we should go
and help as much as we can the people on
Earth and now this help is going to take
several different forms you know going
down there's really interesting
discussions about what it's like to go
from a martian environment in gravity
down to this incredibly messy planet
that we call earth right
some brilliant discussions of that but
also to bring to Earth you know some
some new or actually not so new but
newly implemented political ideals
politics is incredibly important how we
organize our societies who calls the
shots who runs things incredibly
important and the Martians in some
respect have an edge on what's happening
on Earth
so you know there's also you know
products that are coming from Mars
mostly raw materials that's actually
going to become more of an issue with
some of the other uh places but mining
is going on and that's that's quite
important and
um
Earth is able to more or less get
stabilized
and then you know the the matters sort
of come about Anew and they begin to
send more and more people or to insist
at first on sending more and more people
to Mars again to try to deal with the
population problems and the Martians are
posed with a real key problem are they
going to use Force are they going to
resort to war to repel these uh
different
what do you want to call them aggressors
colonizers
uh Pawns of their National or
metanational politics and that's that's
going to lead to the third Martian
Revolution which is going to happen at
the end of blue Mars which we'll
hopefully talk about as a theme in just
a bit so that's massive amounts of
backstory and some of the characters you
know have been developed in the earlier
books and we see them emerging in blue
Mars and some of them are changing you
know some of them are very familiar to
the early uh to the readers of the early
books sax Russell you know uh Michael
and all these different people often
many of whom are in the 100 or near goal
uh you know Jackie they're all going to
attain important uh positions and
represent things going on there so let's
come back and talk a little bit about
the World building that is happening
through terraforming now if you haven't
read any of these books then one of the
things we have to say right off the bat
is Mars is essentially a lifeless planet
and in order for it to be habitable you
not only need a breathable atmosphere
which they're working towards eventually
but lots and lots of water and nitrogen
for the soil that doesn't even have soil
in the proper sense because you know
what we actually need in order to grow
things is organic matter right life
requires previous life you could say so
at the very beginning of red Mars they
begin with things like bacteria and
lichen and all that and you know by the
time that we're getting to Green Mars
they've man it is green Mars in part
because they've managed to make large
parts of Mars green that is caught up
with life or to bring in a very
important
conceptas right which assumes a kind of
philosophical
value in the course of of these novels
um Bloom bars good reason to call it
blue Mars what's blue well you know
ideally water and so a significant part
of the terraforming is actually
producing bodies of water on Mars and
keeping them from freezing so that they
can actually keep up the heating cycle
and make room for all sorts of organisms
by the time that we get to the early
parts of blue Mars we have apex
predators like modified polar bears
which you know if you think about what
that would require an entire food chain
to support them right so Mars is being
developed into
a like Earth
a living Cosmos or at least a cosmos of
great life great variety nowhere near
what's what's on Earth because you know
they're kind of kick-starting things and
among them are human beings and human
beings are the ones who are reshaping
this entire world and who are also
shaping themselves in the process one
last thing that we should talk about
that um
figures into that you know human beings
one of the key aspects of us is
technology and so you know develop new
developments and technology for example
having a space elevator or being able to
colonize Mars at all or being able to
bring these things and Carry Out genetic
manipulation all of those are incredibly
important
one of the things that turns out to be
quite disruptive
is the human quest for if not
immortality at least extended good life
and they do come up with a you know
manner of doing this which is part of
what leads to the instability on Earth
you know the rich can afford these
treatments the poor cannot and the world
is divided between rich and poor most of
the Martians
will in fact use the treatments and this
is going to lead not so much on Mars
which is a growing territory able to
take in quite a few more people although
not as many as the Earth would like to
send up
on Earth this leads to a massive
demographic problem which will actually
have to be solved with uh controlling
natality controlling the amount of
children that people can have
so that's a really important aspect and
then by the time that we get to the end
of blue Mars
we're finding something kind of similar
in terms of treatments but now dealing
with memory uh yet another place to
explore and you could say that the World
building that's going on here
almost entirely Through The Eyes or
dialogue of characters
is revealing to us just how rich complex
and extensive of a universe with worlds
in it we could possibly have so that's
probably enough about World building
that's enough to get everybody up on
speed let's look now at some of the
things that Robinson has had to say that
I think will be quite helpful for us in
understanding the series as a whole and
blue Mars in particular
I've tracked down and read through a
number of recent interviews with Kim
Stanley Robinson that in some way or
another concern this work blew Mars and
the Mars Trilogy as well as some other
important themes and the larger context
of his writing and you could even say
advocacy and I'd like to share them with
you along with some commentary because I
think this will help illuminate some of
the key themes and developments within
the novel itself and to help situate it
within a larger context in which
Robinson is presenting his own work and
we might even say deliberate calling as
an author so the first one is on the
blog of Andrew liptak the interview that
he carried out there I believe in 2000
and 15 or so so he says the Mars books
cover a lot of ground colonization
politics corporations environment what
particular challenges did you have in
assembling the books and Robinson says
well it was a long project but I wasn't
doing anything else in those years
except taking care of my family as a
house husband so I had the time and the
focus to go long the challenges I guess
involved keeping a sense of the flow of
the work and keeping the balance between
the various point of view characters and
then above all figuring out what
happened next in the story and why and
how it was basically the usual novel
writing problems but extended over a
long time and a lot of pages six years
1700 pages
and so then you know uh lit liptak says
well what was the writing process like
in my copy of red Mars your blurb
mentions you were hard at work and
writing green Mars when you wrote the
first book did you know what would be in
store for book three Robinson says I
knew all along I wanted to tell the
story of the terraforming of Mars and
the creation of a new Human Society
there Multicultural and in certain kind
ways kind of utopian compared to now so
I knew that much which was enough to
guide me through the process process of
figuring out what should happen along
the way when I started writing the book
in 1989 I quickly realized it was going
to be a very long book in my agent and
editor of that time said to me Stan we
call that a Trilogy so I shifted the
title from Green Mars which was my idea
for the title for the whole book to red
green and blue Mars now that's quite
interesting isn't it so green ours is of
course in the middle and that was
supposed to be the totality of this
imagine how dense this book would be I
mean these are each one pretty
significant homes if they were bound
together in one single uh volume
then he goes on uh and he's asked what
was the publication process like did you
integrate any new scientific information
about Mars into your books Robinson says
well publication was straightforward led
by my editor uh in England who always
got the books out first that encouraged
me greatly through the process there was
not much new information about Mars in
the years I wrote but what information
there was came out packaged in a huge
Anthology from the University of Arizona
called Mars in 1992 and it gave me new
things to say in green and blue Mars
and then he says something very
interesting here it looked like I'd
saved good things for later in the
trilogy but actually I learned them
while writing and did not know them
before so that was a nice thing to
happen and then he's uh asked another
thing what did you learn from your
California Trilogy you applied to
writing for your Mars Trilogy and then
what did you learn from your Mars books
you applied to the ones that came after
and you know he says the lesson that I
applied to the Mars Trilogy uh had to do
with
um you know writing a novel and moving
around in a point of view from one
character to another so the reader got
different perspectives on the characters
in the story but everything was done on
a larger scale and then he says um I
wanted to do more exposition to talk
about history directly to tell a global
story so there were negative lessons as
well as positive now from the Mars
Trilogy I learned that I could use a
similar format to tell a global story
that covered centuries which helped me
hugely when I wrote later the years of
rice and salt after that the help was
more indirect
I think I could say now this is a
fascinating thing I think I could say
the Mars Trilogy made me Fearless after
doing that I was willing to try anything
so you could say that although the Mars
Trilogy is not a proof of concept as
we're going to see for colonization of
Mars it was a proof of concept for
Robinson and is further writing
um
a little bit later he's he's uh asked
Mars is one of the first destinations
for science fiction ever since someone
misinterpreted the word Canali Wells
Burrows and Bradbury have all set
stories on the red planet did this
figure into how you developed your own
Trilogy and Robinson says Mars is a
great science fiction story space in the
way that they talk about the matter of
Britain when they talk about all the
Arthurian Legends science fiction has
the matter of Mars in each generation
since the time of Percival Lowell the
Mars presented by the scientists has
been taken up by sci-fi writers to
become a new story space
all that got hugely sharpened in focus
in 1969 and 1976 when Mariner and Viking
gave us the planet in so much more
detail than we'd ever had before but the
fundamental truths of the human relation
to Mars were mostly set out by
Bradbury's Martian Chronicles the
Martians are us
we will change there the ghosts of our
stories about the place will always
haunt us when we really get there these
are permanent truths and things I wanted
to join and emphasize in my own Mars
novel so in this interview we see some
reflection on the previous approaches to
Mars the kind of story that he's trying
to tell what he's learning how he's
progressing as an author
then there's this issue about you know
these stories are set in what we could
call our near future you know within
essentially a few lifetimes from now and
you know is it actually possible for us
to terraform Mars to turn it into a
place that we might colonize even escape
to from an earth that is clearly and
lots of trouble and at the time that he
wrote the trilogy that was kind of a
possibility that's why he wrote the
trilogy he's asked about that in several
other interviews so in the sactone
interview
the interviewer says we've made quite a
hash of this planet bottom line can
humans really terraform Mars Is it
feasible is space going to be the next
Frontier for human life
here's what Robinson says
I will say this
I would claim my Mars Trilogy is a good
novel it really is just a three-volume
novel I don't like series as a word
but not a good plan there is no Planet B
and we learn things about Mars since I
finished my Mars Trilogy blue Mars the
last installment came out in 1996 that
actually make terraforming it much more
difficult the surface is poisonous with
perchlorates that's a new finding more
and more we're worried about what Cosmic
radiation does to the brain Mars lack of
a magnetic field means that it's not
going to be safe for humans until you
really are well terraformed and that now
looks to be thousands of years away
then there's nowhere near as much
nitrogen as there ought to be in an
ordinary Planet nobody knows why and you
need nitrogen for a biosphere
terraforming Mars might take a 10 000
years and we've got a hundred year
emergency right here so the time scales
are ridiculously off I have to explain
this every time people bring up Mars
because the Mars Trilogy is still my
most famous work by a long shot
we see a follow-up or you know another
similar line here in the farsight
interview which we'll we'll look at in a
little bit more extensively so the
interviewer says you're a science
fiction writer not a client the climate
scientist but you were a speaker at the
2021 U.N climate change conference as
well as at numerous other science
conferences and you've worked with the
U.S National Science Foundation what can
you contribute that the world's foremost
scientists cannot and this this goes to
what maybe
is here in these works so Robinson
responds in this way
says three things
the future as subject for speculation
the syncretic combination of all the
fields into a holistic vision of
civilization
and lastly narrative is a mode of
knowing
actually I think all scientific papers
are narratives in much the same way
short stories are but they have
different forms and different relations
to their subject materials so that the
narrative element often quite similar to
a detective story is obscured
what science fiction can do is tell the
human stories implied by scientific
discoveries and Venture from
descriptions of what is to speculations
of what ought to be or what we ought to
avoid now I want to pause on that for a
moment so he outlined three important
things future is subject for speculation
that's not a big surprise right
speculative fiction is indeed
speculating uh narrative is a mode of
knowing I think you've heard enough
about that already it's kind of
fascinating to think about scientific
papers as concealing a narrative but
that's really quite true
uh we don't do science in some sort of
synchronic vacuum it is something that
is done as a human set of processes
but here's the most important one I
think the second one
a syncretic combination so bringing
together right syncretizing is fusing
synthesizing taking bits and pieces from
different things and forming them into a
integrated whole
of all the fields
into a holistic Vision okay so you know
what we hear here is something like what
philosophers used to say we're the
discipline that can bring together all
these different fields and make sense of
them in a you know holistic account that
these other fields can't here it's the
novelist who's able to do that but only
a certain kind of novelist but it's not
a syncretic Vision or
um holistic vision of science as such or
the human disciplines
it's of civilization and this all too
often is left out not just by the
scientists but by the engineers by the
bureaucrats by the business people buy
all these other groups the politicians
with their own particular point of view
Robinson is saying that in this he is
bringing together and in his other
novels the possibility of a wider and
deeper vision
so that's important let's come back to
the interview
to what extent he's asked do you believe
climate fiction can influence political
decisions today or make readers take
active steps to mitigate climate change
what makes speculative fiction a
powerful modeling exercise for climate
futures or Futures in general
so Robinson says well people understand
things through narratives including the
future
everyone is the science fiction writer
of their own life isn't that a great
line right we're all speculating about
where we're going even if we're not
doing science fiction proper we're all
doing science fiction in a certain way
when hoping for a good life and thinking
about what might bring that about we are
utopian writers when fearful that bad
things will happen we are dystopian
writers so this is a very natural mode
of thought
when elaborated in detail with thick
texture and some lived imaginative time
a speculative fiction can bring into
life in the mind one possibility or
another which then can be contemplated
as a felt experience and one's present
actions then adjusted accordingly
influenced by experiences that are
fictional yet nevertheless real
he's asked then in your best-selling
Mars Trilogy we follow the process of
terraforming Mars making it more
suitable for human living over two
centuries while climate disasters
devastate the Earth
do you think that making Mars more
habitable to humans is worth the effort
or should we rather concentrate on
maintaining the habitability of the
Earth or are both efforts necessary for
Humanity survival and well-being in the
long term now notice what the author of
this amazing set of novels or rather one
novel and three volumes has to say by
way of response
Mars is irrelevant to us now
we should of course concentrate on
maintaining the habitability of the
earth my Mars Trilogy is a good novel
but not a plan for this moment
if we were to create a sustainable
civilization here on Earth with all of
Earth's creatures prospering then and
only then would Mars become even the
slightest bit interesting to us it would
be a kind of reward for our success we
could think of it in the way my novel
thinks of it as an interesting place
worth exploring more
but until we have solved our problems
here Mars is just a distraction for a
few escapists and so worse than useless
so what is he saying there the plans
that people have like you know uh Elon
Musk proposing we're going to go to Mars
and terraforming that's escapism
that's worse than just doing nothing
what we have to do is fix this planet
that we're stuck on now because
otherwise Mars like he says will be
totally irrelevant because you know
human beings may not even exist anymore
uh another question that is a follow-up
to this climate change efforts basically
seek to return to the earth's climate to
a 20th century state yet the planet's
climate has changed naturally over the
last millions of years without human
interference is it arrogant to try to
preserve the earth's climate in a more
or less static State even if today's
climate changes are man-made rather than
natural now this is going to be a really
interesting answer here
he says no it's not arrogant
it's a survival attempt earth's climate
does fluctuate a great deal due to
Natural changes but what humans have
done in the last 200 years equals
millions of years of natural change so
we're in a new experiment with no
natural precedence we may have initiated
a new Hot House Earth phase which in the
past has meant no ice on the planet and
sea levels
270 feet higher than now
now notice what he says next
actually this is a foolish question I'm
going to stop answering it it does not
deserve an answer I refer you to the
ipcc reports and requests that you
rethink such a foolish idea as that
which is expressed in this question so
he's perfectly willing to call the
interviewer out onto the carpet for
asking there are dumb questions right
there are tendentious questions there
are questions that at this point should
be resolved or settled by intelligent
people and and Robinson is saying well
that's this is one of them and I'm not
going to cooperate with you on this
question so then he's asked one final uh
follow-up do you have anything you want
to add regarding nature and the future
now this is another set of great
observations
nature and natural are words with
particular weights that are perhaps not
relevant now we're part of a biosphere
that sustains us half of the DNA in your
body is not human DNA you are a biome
like a swamp with a particular balance
or ecology that is hard to keep going
and indeed it will only go for a while
after which it falls apart and you die
the world is your body you breathe it
drink it eat it it lives inside you and
you only live and think because this
community is doing well so nature you
our nature nature is you natural is what
happens the world the word is useless as
a divide there is no human apart from
nature you have no thoughts or feelings
without your body and the Earth is your
body so please dispense with that
dichotomy of human nature and attend to
your own health which is to say your
biosphere is health
very interesting Reflections there on
how we as human beings fit into the
natural world we are not something
entirely separate from it
the last interview which is a little bit
longer uh is from polygon and here we're
going to get more into thinking about
Utopia and dystopia and he's going to
bring up something that he learned from
Friedrich Jamison the gramacion square
or as he's going to call it rectangle so
let's let's see what he has to say so
he's asked about science fiction and he
says if you think of Science Fiction as
just a kind of modeling exercise
everybody's a science fiction writer in
their own lives a theme we've seen come
up you make plans based on modeling in
your mind
when you're feeling hopeful
you have a kind of utopian plan if you
do these things you get to a good place
and then when you're afraid you have
these worries that if you do these
things you get to a bad place so the
fundamental exercise of Science Fiction
is a very natural human thing
and then when it gets written down in
long narrative forms like science
fiction novels everybody recognizes the
exercise involved there although when I
say that I realize that actually lots of
people don't like to read science
fiction so they're not recognizing the
way books are the same as what they do
for their own lives that's surprising to
me but it happens a lot
anyway science fiction is a modeling
exercise where all the science fiction
put together especially all the near
future Visions they range from totally
horrible to perhaps quite nice it's
heavier weighted at the disaster and
that at the utopian end maybe because
it's easier or maybe because it's more
shockingly interesting to read it's not
like going to town meetings and reading
blueprints or for plumbing facilities
the utopian end of Science Fiction has a
reputation for being a dull Eat Your
Greens type fiction so there's less of
it compared to the disaster stuff but
there is both and if you read a lot of
it one hopes you're prepared for
anything
that isn't 100 true but you're perhaps
better prepared than if you hadn't read
it in that sense I think science fiction
could be a great teaching tool for
people you can't read all science
fiction and if you're reading nothing
but Space Opera none of this would
obtain
because the problems of spaceships
flying faster than light across the
Galaxy are not always immediately
applicable to the situation we're here
on Earth so it's a specific wing of
Science Fiction I'm talking about that
could be helpful if people read it now
let's pause on that for a minute science
fiction we're always living in it
because we live as he says through and
in narratives this could be said by
Aleister McIntyre who doesn't say that
about science fiction but he does say
that about other fiction he thinks about
you know the Norse etas and you know
commonplace tales and uh Jane Austen and
stuff like that but why not just as much
utopian dystopian fiction like the Mars
Trilogy even if we can't get to Mars and
terraform it there are concerns that are
articulated in here models that are
given to us we might also mention the
person who uh Robinson wrote his
dissertation on Philip K dick who does
similar things in His science fiction
novels he gives us
problems that we can sink our teeth into
existential situations let's go on we
might spend too much time stressing that
here's a question that's being posed to
him the LA Review of Books referred to
you as quote our last great utopian
Visionary what do you think of that
title or at least the utopian Visionary
part he says I think that's fine I've
rolled the dice towards doing utopian
fiction there isn't very much of it the
Canon of Utopias could be listed on your
fingers and toes and yet I think they're
very valuable occasionally they have
effects in the real world Edward
Bellamy's Looking Backward from 1988 was
a big part of the Progressive Movement
120 years ago H.G Wells Utopia novels
had a huge impact on the Bretton Woods
agreement and the settlements after
World War II a good utopian novel can a
generation later or even a few years
later have an impact on how people think
the future should go
then he says something really
interesting here I feel a deep kinship
and love for Ursula K Le Guin and iron
banks these two great utopian writers
they've died and I do feel a bit lonely
for my own generation but I also see a
lot of Young Writers coming up who call
themselves solar Punk or hope Punk or
the new utopians and whatnot they're
forming Schools they're trying to get
enthusiastic about improving our way to
a green future I think they're utopian
but perhaps a little bit outdated or
scared by the term utopia because it so
often used as a weapon to mean
unrealistic and never going to happen so
they make up different terms
I'm glad to see these I don't think
utopian fiction will ever go away it's
like a necessary blueprint for thinking
our way forward so it seems like it's a
good time for utopian fiction
I'm sad at losing colleagues I loved but
I'm encouraged at the way the genre
itself is ratcheting its way back into
people's attention
notice that he's mentioning iron banks
and Ursa Kayla green and all these newer
younger writers and the fact that maybe
Utopia isn't a term we want to
stress anymore maybe we want to do
Utopia and this is going to lead us into
a really interesting set of
discussions
progressions however you want to call it
so the the interviewer says it's
surprising how many classic novels
described as utopian fiction are
actually disguised as dystopian novels
so and Robinson says this is worth
talking about in the gramas rectangle is
referring to AJ gramas the great uh you
know structural uh semantics person
who developed this this four-part square
or a rectangle which we can perhaps talk
about later
in the grumas rectangle there's the
thing that's not you and then there's
the thing that's against you and these
are not the same in that model
the opposite of Utopia is dystopia
but the thing against you is anti-utopia
what that model is saying is if you try
to get to Utopia it would necessarily be
bad so it's against the idea of Utopia
itself so now we've got Utopia dystopia
anti-utopia
it's just saying we tried and we lost
but anti-utopian ideas say that trying
to make Utopias necessarily rebound and
Boomerang into disaster
for example
1984 is a dystopia
big brother is not trying to make you
happy that government is putting its
boot on your neck
but Brave New World is the great
anti-utopian novel where they try to
make everybody happy so they drug them
and electroshock them and now then
everyone's supposed to be happy and it
doesn't work
those two very very famous novel service
the great dystopia and the Great
anti-utopia and the fourth term in the
rectangle this comes out of Frederick
Jameson's Marxist literary criticism and
of course gramas's semantic Square would
be
anti-anti-utopian this gets super
mysterious but it just refers to
insisting it's possible to make a better
world
so that's the mysterious fourth term in
the particular rectangle I am
anti-anti-utopian but I'm also utopian
which is a little bit more obvious so
very interesting set of Reflections
there and again going to the issue of
should we label things as utopian well
then that immediately you know raises
the dystopia and the anti-utopia but
maybe there's this fourth possibility
which is
anti-anti-utopian and says we do got to
make it better right this is
absolutely essential and we could think
about it in terms of environmental
catastrophe we better make it better or
there's no we at after a while or we
could think of it in terms of the
classical conception of the good life a
good life that is not just an individual
good life but a good life in community
he goes on and uh the interviewer says
supposedly utopian fiction can't have a
story
because it can't have conflicts or
imperfections how have you approached
that problem as you're thinking about
this philosophically
this is something that really Bears on
these Works he says so one strategy is
that you show that in a Utopia it's
still possible to be extremely unhappy
and he did this in Pacific Edge in a
Utopia there's still a falls in love
with B who's in love with C who is in
love with a and they're all miserable or
a is in love with b and then he dies
Utopia does not guarantee human
happiness it just takes away unnecessary
suffering by way of political oppression
another way is to Define utopia as not a
perfect end-state Society that's
impossible anyway you define it as a
progressive movement in history with
each generation doing better than the
generation before in substantial ways in
terms of equality Justice and
sustainability it's a process not a
product so Utopia is just a name for one
kind of story I do that a lot lastly
iron banks was great at this in his
Space Opera novels there was a
post-scarcity galactic Utopia but it's
always under assault by forces that
don't like it he was one of the greatest
writers of my generation in so many ways
but especially in terms of stage
business and exciting plots iron was the
master
his utopian society always had to defend
itself sometimes quite violently so
defense of Utopia becomes like a war
zone and suddenly you're back to war
novels and then the Utopia sits there as
kind of a given but it has to be
defended
that's a great strategy that I haven't
used as much as iron
I learned from him and I learned from
the queen she always went right to the
heart of the contradictions
if everybody's free to do what they want
who takes out the trash what happens
when there's a drought is there a police
force if there isn't how do you control
a violent person in the dispossessed she
basically went to every one of the
problems Utopia would have in terms of
contradiction and dramatize that I
learned a lot from her too and I would
say those lessons are indeed reflected
in these works we have many characters
who are not happy or not entirely happy
and we see growth taking place a
continual progression as he's talking
about one which is continually
threatened up on Mars both by forces on
Mars and by forces on Earth and even in
the expansion to the rest of the solar
system so I think that these interviews
might be helpful for putting us into the
right frame of mind for thinking about
some of the great philosophical themes
that are being worked out in blue Mars
one of the aspects running throughout
the Mars Trilogy as a whole and
particularly in blue Mars is what we saw
Robinson calling in one of the
interviews
anti-anti-utopianism and that is you
could say putting forth we might call it
a new paradigm that is embodied and
talked about and articulated over and
over again on Mars and through this a
sort of a counterbalance to earth when
it comes to the other planets as well
which we're going to see some brief
engagement with and hopefully we'll get
to talking about that in a bit now is it
a new paradigm or is it rather a
paradigm that isn't completely new but
often is frustrated is not allowed to be
applied and take place except in limited
ways in the world and history of that we
know here on Earth I think that's the
actual answer and I want to begin sort
of deep in the book jumping kind of
ahead in the future
we have this really interesting chapter
viriditas which is a really important
concept and also you know this this
whole discussion here where we're seeing
this new transition for for Humanity and
we get this really interesting summary
of
what it is that a future historian is
going to tell us so I'm going to begin
here
um
says in all these outer orbits the
Martian co-ops were extremely busy
helping martians and terrans to emigrate
to one of the new Little Worlds and as
the process continued in a hundred and
then thousand asteroids and moonlets
were given a local habitation and a name
the process took fire becoming what some
called the explosive diaspora others
simply the accelerando people took to
the idea and the project gathered an
energy that was felt everywhere
expressing a growing sense of Humanity's
power to create its vitality and variety
and the accelerando was also understood
to be Humanity's response to the Supreme
crisis of the population surge a crisis
so severe it made the Terran flood of
2129 look in comparison like no more
than a bad high tide many historians
sociologists and other social observers
attempted to explain the vibrant nature
of this most self-conscious age one
school of historians the Deluge group
looked back to the great Terran flood
and declared it had been the cause of
the New Renaissance a force jumped to a
higher level another school of thought
put forth the so-called technical
explanation Humanity had passed through
one of the transitions to a new level of
technological competence they maintained
as it had every half century or so right
back to the first Industrial Revolution
the Deluge group tended to use the term
diaspora the Technics the term
accelerando then in the 2170s The
Martian historian Charlotte dorsia
brevia wrote and published a dense
multi-volume analytical meta history as
she called it which maintained that the
great flood had indeed served as a
trigger point and Technical advances is
the enabling mechanism but the specific
character of the New Renaissance had
been caused by something much more
fundamental which was the shift from one
kind of global socioeconomic system to
the next
she described what she called a residual
emergent complex of overlapping
paradigms in which each great
socioeconomic era was composed of
roughly equal parts of the systems
immediately adjacent to it in past and
future
the periods immediately before and after
were not the only ones involved however
they form the bulk of a system and
comprised its most contradictory
components but additional important
features came from particularly
persistent aspects of more archaic
systems and also faint hesitant
intuitions of developments that would
not flower until much later
feudalism therefore to take one example
was for Charlotte made up of a clash of
the residual system of absolute
religious monarchy the emerging system
of capitalism with important Echoes of
the more archaic tribal caste and faint
foreshadowings of later individualist
humanisms the Clashing of these forces
shifted over time until the Renaissance
of the 16th century ushered in the age
of capitalism capitalism then was
composed of clashing elements of the
residual feudalism and an emergent
future order that was only now being
defined in their own time which
Charlotte called democracy and now
Charlotte claimed they were on Mars at
least
in in the Democratic age itself
capitalism had therefore like all other
ages been the combination of two systems
in very sharp opposition to each other
the incompatibility of its constituent
Parts was underlined by the unfortunate
experience of capitalism's critical
Shadow socialism which had theorize true
democracy and called for it but in the
attempt to enact it had used the methods
at hand for its time the same feudal
methods so prevalent in capitalism
itself so that both versions of the mix
had ended up as destructive and unjust
as their common residual parent the
feudal hierarchies in capitalism had
been mirrored in the lived socialist
experiments and so the whole era had
remained a highly charged chaotic
struggle exhibitings different versions
of the dynamic struggle between
feudalism and democracy Now notice where
we're going to go next
but the Democratic age had finally on
Mars emerged from the Capital Stage and
this age too following the logic of
Charlotte's Paradigm was necessarily A
Clash of residual and emergent between
the contentious competitive residuals of
the capitalist system and some emergent
aspects of an order Beyond democracy one
that could not be fully characterized
yet as it had never existed but which
Charlotte ventured to call Harmony or
general Goodwill
this speculative leap she made partly by
studying closely how different
Cooperative economics was from
capitalism and partly by taking an even
larger meta-historical perspective and
identifying a broad general movement in
history which commentators called her
big seesaw movement from the deep
residuals of the dominance hierarchies
of our primate ancestors on the Savannah
toward the very slow uncertain difficult
unpredict predetermined free emergence
of a pure Harmony inequality which that
would then characterize the very truest
democracy
both of these the long-term clashing
elements had always existed Charlotte
maintained creating the big seesaw with
the balance between them slowly and a
regularly shifting over all human
history dominance hierarchies that
underlaying every system ever realized
so far but at the same time Democratic
Values had always been a hope and a goal
expressed in every primate sense of self
and resentment of hierarchies that after
all had to be imposed by force and so as
the Seesaw of this Meta Meta history had
shifted balance over the centuries the
noticeably imperfect attempts to
Institute democracy had slowly gained
power thus a very small percentage of
humans had counted as true equals in
slave holding societies like ancient
Greece or revolutionary America and in
the circle of true equals it only
enlarged a bit more in the later
capitalist democracies but as each
system moved on to the next the circle
of equal citizens had bloomed wider by a
slighter great margin until now not only
were all humans in theory at least
anyway equal but consideration was being
given to other animals even to plants
ecosystems and the elements themselves
these last extensions of citizenship
Charlotte considered to be among the
foreshadowings of the emergence system
that might come after democracy per se
Charlotte's postulated period of utopian
Harmony
these glimmerings were faint and
Charlotte's distant hope for future a
vague hypothesis when sax Russell read
the later volumes of her work pouring
avidly over the endless examples and
Arguments for this account is a severe
abridgement of her work a mere abstract
only and I won't go on further but this
is uh quite important what do we have
here Charlotte is representing and she's
by the way also coming from dorsia
brevia which is one of the places on
Mars where this thought and work is
being carried out as we'll talk about
but what we've got here is this
Democratic age which is
anti-anti-utopian in the way that
Robinson has articulated that using
gramas's semantic Square
and it's motivated by or sandwiched
bookended by an age yet to come that of
Harmony which is indeed utopian
and notice what Robinson is doing here
in this I think this is actually one of
the passages that holds the entire thing
together and and motivates what um
Robinson is doing in the entire work
let's see some sort of manifestations of
this I think the next passage that we
want to go to in blue Mars is early on
in the chapter a new constitution
where they are forming a congress
so you know and again
dorsia brevia plays an important role
the Constitutional Scholars from dorsia
brevia agreed that Congress should be
conducted by members of the voting
delegations and the final result then
voted on by the populace at large so
what do we have here representative
politics Democratic politics not in the
sense that we're used to today where
money and party affiliation has
essentially corrupted the process at so
many different levels almost
irredeemably at least here in the United
States
but genuine representative
politics so
what do we have going on here Charlotte
who had helped draft The Dorsey abrevia
document 12 and Mars years before had
led a group sense that in working up
plans for a government in anticipation
of a successful Revolution so there's
groundwork being laid there right they
were not the only ones to have done this
schools in South fossa and at the
University in sabishi and taught courses
in the matter and many of the young
natives in the warehouse were well
versed in the ideas or the issues they
were tackling it's kind of scary art
remarked to Nadia win a revolution and a
bunch of lawyers pop out of the woodwork
and so what do they actually have
Charlotte's group made a list of
potential delegates to a congress
constitutional Congress including all
Martian settlements with populations
over 500. quite a few people would
therefore be represented twice Nadia
pointed out once by location and again
by political affiliation the few groups
not on the list complain to the new new
committee which allowed almost all
petitioners to join so it's it's a very
broad perspective that is being taken in
and this is this is essential to any
sort of real Democratic politics you
take in everybody's voices so
I will just read this off
um after about a week's jockeying they
had enough agreement to call for a vote
of approval of the delegate list
so they suddenly had a real Congress it
was made up of the following delegations
with anywhere from one to ten people in
each delegation
towns akaran Nicosia Cairo Odessa and we
could go on and on and on there are you
know several dozen towns here political
parties and organizations
boonians the followers of you know John
Boone's Vision Reds those who want to
keep Mars as much as possible not
terraformed and sometimes engage in
violent action
the followers of our Katie who dies very
early on in the series in in red Mars
but who is one of the first people to
say we don't have to do things the way
that the Earth people want us to do them
uh shelling shelling nistas Mars first
which will become the most important
political party on Mars free well
actually no free Mars rather the KA
Praxis which is a Swiss uh meta National
company who wound up being on Mars and
having an important role in things the
kahirion majari league green Mars those
who want to terraform and bring about
life further the United Nations Nations
transitional Authority one of the
enemies for a long time of that
there the editorial board of the Journal
of aerological studies academics are
playing a role in this the space
elevator Authority Christian democrats
The Meta National economic activity
Coordination Committee right the the
metanats are some of the people who are
the most problematic or the forces most
problematic on Earth
um begonia neo-marxas Friends of the
Earth biotique
separation de atmosphere
uh General meetings then he says began
in the morning around the table moved
out into the small working groups and
they talk about what's going on with
this Committee in the first week many
arguments con concerns simply what a
constitution was what form it should
take and whether they should have one at
all Charlotte called this The Meta
conflict the argument about what the
argument was about a very important
matter she said when she saw Nadia
squint unhappily why because in settling
it we set the limits on what we can
decide
if we decide to include economic and
social issues in the Constitution for
instance this will be a very different
kind of thing than if we stick to purely
political or legal matters or even a
very general statement of principles and
they decide to take the Bold route now
there's a number of of things that I
want to bring up in here that show us
you know the aspects of the new paradigm
that is being developed on Mars and
really being offered to us
you know under the table you might say
as readers of this by Kim Stanley
Robinson one of the very important
things that comes up at the beginning
is a new constitution is the issue of
Rights
so you know
there's a uh sort of conflict there
between as as Nadia says people claiming
that some fundamental right is foreign
to their culture that stinks no matter
who says it fundamentalist Patriarchs
leninists metanats I don't care who
they're not going to get away with it
here not if I can help it art noticed
more than a few delegates frowning at
this sentiment which struck them as a
version of Western secular relativism or
perhaps John Boone's hyper-americanism
opposition to metanats it included many
people trying to hold on to their older
cultures and these often had their
hierarchies notice that term pretty well
intact the ones at the top end of the
hierarchies like them that way and so
did a surprisingly large number of
people further down the ladder but
the Young Nation the young Martian
natives however looked surprised that
this was even a issue to them the
fundamental rights were innate and
irrevocable and any challenge to them
that struck them as just one more of the
many emotional scars that the East say
we're always revealing as a result of
their traumatic dysfunctional Terran
upbringings ariadne one of the most
prominent of the young natives stood up
to say that the dorsia brevia group had
studied many Terran human rights
documents and had written a
comprehensive list of Their Own
the new Master list of fundamental
individual rights was available for
discussion and she implied adoption
wholesale some argued about one point or
another but it was generally agreed that
a global Bill of Rights of some kind
should be on the table so Martian values
as they existed in Martian year 52 were
about to be codified and made a
principal component in the Constitution
the exact nature of these rights was
still a matter of controversy the
so-called political rights were
generally agreed to be self-evident
things citizens are free to do things
governments were forbidden to do like
habeas corpus freedom of movement speech
Association religion abandoned weapons
all of these were approved by a vast
majority of Martian natives though there
were some easy from places like
Singapore Cuba Indonesia Thailand China
who looked to scans at so much emphasis
on individual liberty
other delegates had reservations about a
different kind of right the so-called
social or economic rights such as the
right to housing Health Care education
employment a share of the value
generated by natural resource use
many you say delegates without actual
experience in Terran government were
quite worried about these pointing out
that it was dangerous to enshrine such
things in the Constitution
it had been done on Earth they said and
then when it was found impossible to
meet with such promises the Constitution
guaranteeing them was seen as a
propaganda device and flouted in other
areas as well until it became a bad joke
even so Mikhail said sharply if you
can't afford housing then it is your
right to vote that it is the bad joke
the young natives agreed as did many
others there so economic or social
rights were on the table too and
arguments over how to actually guarantee
these rights in practice continued
through many a long session political
socialists all one Nadia said let's make
all the rights work so imagine this
again not utopian but
anti-anti-utopian working through the
problems in granting to people granting
to human beings a full set of Rights
so a little bit later in a new
constitution uh we hear what's you know
0.4 in the dorsa brevia agreement
everybody's work is their own and the
worth of it cannot be taken away the
various modes of production belong to
those who created them and to the common
good of the future Generations
it says that the world is something we
all Steward together so you know very
often we think of rights as well if we
Grant people rights they're going to be
too individualistic and they're not
going to like you know they're all going
to take their share this
has a sustainability future Generations
aspect to it
so the it goes on that has been the work
that has been our work these last 50
years in the system we've developed all
economic Enterprises are to be small
cooperatives owned by their workers and
no one else they hire their management
or manage themselves industry guilds and
Co-op associations will form the larger
structures necessary to regulate trade
and the market share capital and create
uh credit and then somebody says these
are nothing but ideas it's utopianism
and nothing more
and then not at all the system is based
on models from Terror and history and
it's various parts have all been tested
on both worlds and succeeded very well
now here's a really important
point
you don't know about this partly because
you're ignorant and partly because meta
nationalism itself steadfastly ignored
and denied all our alternatives to it
but most of all most of our micro
economy has been in successful operation
for centuries in the Mondragon region of
Spain the different parts of the macro
economy have been used in the
pseudo-metnet Praxis in Switzerland in
India's state of Kerala and Bhutan he
goes on and on and on right
and these organizations were the
precursors to our economy now notice
this line which will be Democratic in a
way capitalism never even tried to be
a synthesis of systems
right so this is uh you know again
advancing some important ideas and you
know through this characters Robinson is
pointing out these are not utopian ideas
again
anti-anti-utopia these have been done
they actually do work we have to provide
the Resolute support
for them right
in Green Earth we have this very
interesting discussion between Michael
and sax and we're going to come and near
go and we're going to come back to
Michael in just a bit
um
this is this is what near goal is saying
Mars is a mirror in which Tara sees its
own Essence the move to Mars was a
purifying Voyage stripping away all but
the most important things what arrived
in the end was Taryn through and through
and what has happened since there has
been an expression of Terran thought and
Taran jeans and so more than any
material Aid in scarce metals or new
genetic strains we
can most help the home planet by serving
as a way for you
you Terrence to see yourselves and as a
way to map out an unimaginable immensity
in our small way we do our part to
create the great civilization that
trembles on the brink of becoming We Are
The Primitives of an unknown
civilization that's what it looks like
to us on Mars anyway a long Evolution
through the centuries towards Justice
and peace as people learn more they
understand better their dependence on
each other and on their world on Mars we
have seen that the best way to express
this interdependence is to live for
giving in a culture of compassion every
person free and equal in the sight of
all working together for the good of of
all it's that work that makes us most
free no hierarchy is worth acknowledging
but this one the more we give the
greater we become now in the midst of a
great flood spurred by the great flood
we see the flowering of this culture of
compassion emerging on both Two Worlds
at once now that does get a little bit
utopian right because we're going to see
there's there's lots and lots of
problems not just you know on Earth but
also on Mars as well
um so let's go back a little bit to this
very interesting uh discussion which
again brings up semiotic squares right
and
um
there's uh it's sax and Michael Michael
remembers the psychotherapist and sort
of a a voice in the ears of so many of
the other characters and they bring up
this uh
they're talking about remember
remembering things and Trauma
Michael says there were 50 women in the
first hundred odds are that more than
one of them were abused by men in their
life more likely 10 or 15 if the
statistics are to be believed sexually
violated struck mistreated that's just
the way it was old Paradigm one of
hierarchy right
Sac says it's hard to believe Michael
says yes
sax recalled hitting Phyllis in the jaw
Phyllis is the uh one of the hundred who
uh not only you know becomes part of the
power structure trying to uh let the Met
Nats control Mars but also
um captures sacks and
um does horrible things to him
um
everyone has their reasons Michael said
startling him or so they think he tried
to explain in his usual Michael fashion
to make it something other than plain
evil
at the base of human culture is a
neurotic response to people's earliest
psychic wounds before birth and during
infancy people exist in a narcissistic
Oceanic Bliss in which the individual of
the universe then sometime in late
infancy we come to the awareness where
separate individuals different from our
mother and everyone else this is a blow
from which we never completely recover
there are several neurotic strategies
used to try to deal with it first
merging back into the mother
then denying the mother and shifting our
ego ideal to the father this strategy
often lasts forever and the people of
that Culture worship their King and
their father God and so on or the ego
ideal might shift again to abstract
ideas or to the Brotherhood of Man there
are names and full descriptions for all
of these complexes the dionysian the
Persian the apollonian the heraclan they
all exist and they're all neurotic in
that they all lead to misogyny except
for the dionysian complex
this is one of your semantic rectangles
sax asked apprehensively yes
the apollonian and hair Clan complexes
might describe Terran industrial
societies the Persian its earlier
cultures with strong remnants of course
right up to this day and they are all
three patriarchal
they all denied the maternal which was
connected in patriarchy with the body
and nature the feminine was Instinct the
body and nature well the masculine was
reason in mind and law and the law ruled
sax fascinated by so much throwing
together said only and on Mars
well on Mars it may be that the ego
ideal is Shifting back to the maternal
to the dionysian again or to some kind
of post-edible reintegration with nature
which we are still in the process of
inventing some new complex that would
not be so subject
to an erotic over investment
sax shook his head it was amazing how
floridely elaborated a pseudoscience
could get a compensation technique
perhaps a desperate attempt to be more
like physics but what they did not
understand is that physics while
admittedly complicated was always trying
very hard to become simpler
Michael however was continuing to
elaborate correlated to patriarchy was
capitalism he was saying a hierarchical
system in which most men had been
exploited economically also treated like
animals poison betrayed shoved around
shot and even in the best of
circumstances under constant threat of
being tossed aside out of a job poor
unable to provide for loved dependence
hungry humiliated
some trapped in this unfortunate system
took out their rage at their plight on
whoever whoever they could even if that
turned out to be their loved ones the
people most likely to give them Comfort
it was illogical and even stupid brutal
and stupid yes Michael Shrugged he
didn't like where this train of
reasoning had led him
it sounded to like to sax like the
implication that many men's actions
indicated that they were alas fairly
stupid and the limbic array got all
twisted in some Minds Michael was going
on trying to Veer away from that to make
a decent explanation
so he goes he goes on sax interprets him
as explaining away evil when Michael
arguably I think uh on the part of
Robinson is actually explaining
something about the possibility for
moving past trauma and we nowadays call
it disorder rather than Neurosis but
complexes that tend to make people
either Cooperative with or accepting of
these very unequal undemocratic
hierarchical systems which don't benefit
them
even when they're allowed to kick
downward
going on a little bit further
coming back to free Mars free Mars was
now a political party the biggest on
Mars it had not always been that way it
begun to something more like a network
of friends or the part of the
underground that lived in the demimoned
mostly ex-students in the university in
sabishi or later the members of a very
loose Association of communities in the
tented canyons and clandestine clubs in
the city and so forth a kind of a vague
umbrella term for those sympathetic to
the underground and not followers of any
more specific political movement or
philosophy just something they said in
fact free Mars something like that can
be a catalyst can take on its own sort
of
impetus its own value its own capacity
to connect people
So It Goes On
in many ways it had been near gaul's
creation so many of the natives had been
interested in autonomy and the various
parties based on thoughts of one early
settler another did not appeal to them
and they wanted something new
so nergal had traveled around the planet
and stayed with people who organized
meetings or discussions and this had
gone on for so long eventually people
wanted a name people want name for
things names for things and so free Mars
and in the revolution we're talking
about the second revolution it had
become a rallying point for the natives
rising up out of society as a kind of
emergent phenomenon and with many more
people declaring themselves members than
one would have guessed possible Millions
the native majority the very definition
of the revolution in fact the main
reason for its success free Mars as a
sentence as an imperative and they had
done it
so you know this is is quite important
we're going to see that there are
challenges with that Jackie is going to
try to take control we also have other
characters getting getting involved as
well
um
we come back to the the discussion of uh
hierarchy and property and patriarchy
and we have a very interesting
engagement between Saks and bow here
um
and it's bringing up Michael sacks
thought he could see what Michael meant
about culture keeps progressing there
were rapid changes and attitudes to many
things vertis Vandal as Bella called it
mutation of values but they still lived
in a society struggling with archaisms
of All Sorts primates banding into
tribes guarding a territory praying to a
god like a cartoon parent
sometimes I don't think there's been any
progress at all he said feeling
strangely disconsolate but sacks Michael
protested right here on Mars we have
seen both patriarchy and property
brought to an end it's one of the
greatest achievements in human history
if true Sac says
don't you think women have as much power
as men now as far as I can tell
perhaps even more when it comes to
reproduction well that would make sense
and the land is in the stairs the shared
stewardship of everybody we still own
personal items as property but land as
property has never happened here there's
a new social reality
very important term and he says we
struggle with it every day
so they did and sax remembered how
bitter the conflicts had been in the old
days when property and capital had been
the order of the day yes perhaps it was
true
patriarchy and property were now in the
process of being dismantled at least on
Mars at least for now
as with string theory it might take a
long time to work it in any proper state
after all sax himself who had no
prejudices whatsoever had been amazed to
see a woman mathematician at work or a
more precise a woman genius by whom he'd
been promptly hypnotized so to speak
with every other man in the theory group
to the point of being quite distraught
by her departure uneasily he said on
Earth people seem to be fighting as much
as before even Michael had to admit it
there are too many people down there and
more all the time you saw what it was
like during our visit
as long as Earth is in that situation
Mars is under threat and so we fight it
up here too
sax took the point
in a way it was comforting human
behavior has not irreducibly stupid or
evil but as responding semi-rationally
to a given historical situation a danger
seeing what one could with the notion
that there might not be enough for all
doing everything possible to protect
one's Offspring which of course
endangered all Offspring by the
aggregate of individual selfish selfish
actions but at least it could be called
an attempt to reason
F first approximation
it's not as bad as it was anyway Michael
was saying even on Earth people are
having few far fewer children and
they're reorganizing into collectives
pretty well considering the flood and
all the trouble that preceded it a lot
of new social movements down there a lot
of them inspired by what we're doing
here and by what nergel does
now again we see this this uh constant
theme of the possibility of a new
paradigm a new society that becomes
possible on this imaginary Mars which
Robinson is advocating for us to try to
make here on Earth before it's too late
right
um
I think that's probably enough about
these these Grand themes you see where
it's going it's once again to use the
very important terms not utopianism in
the foolish uh pollyanish unrealistic
sense but which is a end point right
um but Auntie anti-autopianism going
against those who had set up dystopias
or those who are dismissive of Utopia as
such always raising the the problems
with it as a reason to not do anything
different to stay where we currently are
which is on a track that is not static
but Dynamic and leading eventually to
according to Robinson
environmental and
um
human on every level catastrophe so
these are some I think very very
important philosophical themes all
bringing them all come coming together
developing over time looked at from
multiple points of view through the eyes
and actions and words of the various
characters involved in this including
that meta-historical analysis that we
began with here
we are already now past the 90 minute
mark that I had originally set for this
online series each of the videos and
I've been transgressing that limit quite
a bit in the last year so so I'm going
to try to wrap this one up here you
notice there's a lot of great
philosophical themes interwoven into
this this series and I hope that you
will be you know provoked or perhaps uh
cajoled into getting your hands on them
and reading them if you haven't already
and if you have read them I hope you got
something out of this discussion of the
Mars Trilogy or as Robinson himself
tells us this 17 100 page single novel
in three volumes and you know we've got
plenty of other great science fiction
fantasy horror other specular to fiction
authors and series coming up slated for
the rest of the year I hope that you'll
join me for some of those sessions as
well and if you're you know this is
number 69 in the series so if you're
interested in seeing who else there's a
link to the playlist and you'll also see
one at the very end of this video so
just click on that and you can see all
of the other previous sessions authors
who we've covered and you know the
intention is to keep this series going
on for as long as people are interested
in it and as long as there's more
authors and series and narrative worlds
for me to explore the odds of running
out of those pretty low so let's bring
this one to a close thanks for watching
this far and I hope that you will take a
look or a relook at this wonderful Mars
Trail Trilogy by Kim Stanley Robinson
[Music]